but let's be positive for a second so
from a woman's perspective the women
answer this right now from a woman's
perspective what are the best traits and
qualities that a man should be looking
for in a wife and a mother
a wife and a mother um good with kids
um first and foremost if you don't have
kids and I would just say like she has
to get on your program and I agree with
what he said agree agreeable but not
disagreeable yeah I mean you just don't
want a girl that you're arguing with all
the time that's a headache guys don't
want to come home to you it's like they
they fight battles at work every day you
want to come home and fight with your
girl no gotcha how many of your close
girlfriends are married or have kids now
two so that two out of
four okay so you don't have a lot of
girlfriends no okay
maybe be nice to whales baby green peace
okay big girls need love too so you're
saying that
um don't be disagreeable and prove that
you're actually good with kids prior to
Me Knocking you up
Fair okay anything you want to add to
that what a man should be looking for in
a wife a mother yeah I liked I liked my
brother's girlfriend because this girl
went to culinary school to cook for my
brother yeah you're not mad she's not
even a chef she went she was calling
herself to cook she's an engineer she
was like you know what I want to cook
for my man she goes to culinary school
okay I'm not are they still together
yeah he just put post how do you think
she got the ring
as I say the stomach is the key to a
good relationship
gotcha and then you have just to be
clear you have five brothers you're one
of nine what are you I'm one of ten one
of ten oh wow sorry for the one that I
forgot okay yeah one of ten and they're
how many boys how many girls it's five
five okay and to be clear if you could
paint the perfect woman for all five of
your brothers not each one of them I
don't need you know Bill's ideal wife
and then Adam's ideal wife and then
Larry's ideal wife but like if you can
if there's a like a
I don't want to use the term unicorn
because you know we all know those don't
exist
um
what type of woman if you can paint an
ideal woman ideal perfect for your five
brothers okay so one she can't be a hoe
I can't she can't be sleeping around all
around the town no no no 304 is for my
brothers gotcha two okay she's got a
um
she has to work hard yeah so because
like raising kids is hard so I feel like
you should have someone that like is a
hard worker okay
um I would also say um being agreeable
and like listening to him I really like
that my brother's girlfriends um
like they don't really argue with what
they say they just kind of follow okay
um
when you say work hard like a job work
hard no it doesn't have to be a job I
just think like work ethic is good like
don't be lazy yeah okay so not
disagreeable be a good worker be able to
cook a little bit oh not attended with
kids not super attention by the way real
quick I'd like to introduce your
brothers to Natalia over there because
as you're saying all this I'm like look
at my girl Nat
just agreeable
never disagreeing always a good worker I
know if they're a single if my brothers
were single I would totally set them up
with her all right listen there's a lot
of dudes out there that are paying for
now's bath water these days in super
chats okay so um Madison you have any
brothers uh yes I do wait can I add one
yeah in shape sorry and shape done we
know you're not a Greenpeace over here
right you're not trying to save the
whale you know that thanks okay so you
have how many brothers I have one
brother how old is he he is 37. is he
married kids married okay so for your
brother other and let's say Adam over
here looking for a wife right there's a
ton of dudes in the audience out there
how you guys doing good to see you
um what would the perfect wife and
mother look like for your brother and
Adam over here and the men out there I
would say someone who's confident secure
with themselves because insecurities
brings a lot of attention sinking and
just needing the reassurance constantly
I would also say someone who's very warm
loving kind caring that's very also
almost selfless
um and that they can yeah someone who's
a good teammate like a good partner I'm
noticing they want to be a better person
nobody's saying it like
brings home the bacon you know making
money like it's not that's partner a
team partner that's that's part of it
someone who can help you be the best
person that you can be and you both lift
each other up all right I mean what is
money what does money to a guy who has
it and my brothers are not bums you know
what I mean
that's great if your girl
can make money and do that and be a
complimentary type person but I don't
think men are looking for that there's a
sexual market value stat out there where
like what women work for it's like a
it's like a pie chart
um and it I did I remember this it's
like a woman's looking for a guy with
resources uh who can provide protect be
good looking it's like an equitable kind
of share like it's a pie chart that gets
broken up whereas men 80 of it is looks
and then the other 20 is like what you
do your age what you're providing like
all that so it's a different Dynamic
right a lot of a lot of younger men
though aren't going to be happy and are
secure enough to date a girl that makes
a lot of money
well a lot of younger men are probably
dating a young girl who's making a lot
of money well I just I think it's I just
think it's nothing to men and like like
you know I do well with the channel and
like that's why when you ask in the
beginning how is your dating life
changed I'm like it's the same guys
don't care like guys don't care though
no they're there I don't know you're a
public figure at this point there's some
men that gets you an extra point for
sure you've been married some men would
have a hard time dating yeah you've been
no if anything I think like most guys
would prefer a girl with like not on
social media than on it yeah I would say
it almost like loses you let me tell you
a story like speaking of that let me
tell you a story so I meet this girl
very pretty girl and she's in The
Nightlife business in Miami
and um you know obviously you do the
same pleasantries hey how you doing this
that the other and then naturally it's
like so what's your Instagram obviously
you do that and I get her Instagram
and I sent her a text I said by the way
I'm really impressed with your Instagram
she goes why I have like a couple
hundred followers and I go exactly I go
do you know how rare it is
for a pretty girl
that lives in Miami that works in
Nightlife to not have like soldering
going on all over their Instagram page
like that is such an impressive quality
so the fact that she had whatever a
couple hundred couple thousand followers
I don't know and it was just like nice
photos just her being pretty family
versus like booty shot booty boom
titties out like it was like so
refreshing and I said wow I'm so
impressed by you but most girls don't
got that in that type of uh category
because men you know if you're looking
for that type of girl
you steer clear from the uh the girls
with a million followers if you know
what I'm saying okay that's rant over uh
you've been married you're married for
10 years you now have a unicorn by your
side uh you told me you you used to date
around a little bit in your younger days
uh based on your track record what is
the best uh traits and characteristics
for a wife and mother
well I think what she said first which
is like good with kids right if you're
planning to have kids with them are they
a good mom number one yeah for me and
she was a teacher before so I was like
that's amazing because like if you've
been a teacher as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible